I am new to the RIFE machine.
How do I navigate to all the programs?
Well, I did make a video about this,
how to navigate, but typically at your, you know,
when you open up your computer,
you'll see your home screen.
I have videos on your home screen
for how to use your RIFE machine.
And I think on one of those,
you would go into how to navigate,
but then I created a new video
on how to navigate your computer.
So go to your frequency course,
go to the frequency healing course,
and you'll see that on the home,
on the first module of the frequency,
healing course, how to navigate through your programs.
And the only people that have trouble
navigating to the programs,
people have never used any Microsoft product before
because it's basically based on all the Microsoft icons.
So you could go back a screen and, you know,
you'll go to open program.
So don't be afraid of messing things up.
You only say time you mess things up.
If you're drained things to something
and dropped them somewhere, different files or,
so it's all based upon your programs.
You're based upon different file folders
that each file folder has a program in it.
And any of those programs you can run
with your RIFE machine.
So don't be afraid of it.
Anything you would possibly screw up
is something we could fix.
So, you know, we do get calls from people
that get a RIFE machine for us to our full program
and then, you know, week later,
they're still not running their program
because they're afraid to open it up
and try different things.
Everybody gets access to the frequency healing course.
And it has every instruction you could possibly think of
in there every time someone comes up with a question
that is a new question.
We've been doing this a long time.
We still get some new questions.
Anytime they will make a video on it.
So, and there are the frequency healing course.
All our videos are on our video site too.
So you could literally search the video site
with the search button
and you'd probably get a video of that, your answer.
And even searching our website,
you could get an answer to most of those questions.
So don't feel bad about looking for these things
on our sites.
And if worse case scenario, make sure you call us
and we can walk you through that.